اغسل يديك وغطي أنفك
وفمك عندما تعطس وتجنب الحشود الكبيرة
ولكن بالإضافة إلى كل هذه
الاحتياطات الجديدة لفيروس كورونا ، هناك
عنصر حاسم ينقصه شيء نلمسه جميعًا
مرارًا وتكرارًا كل يوم
يمكن أن يعيش القليل منا بدون هواتفنا
الذكية.  غالبًا ما يتم نسيان
الرابط بين الخدمات العامة
ووجهنا وأيضًا أن تكون على دراية
بالأشياء التي تلمسها عادةً وأن
الشيء الأكثر شيوعًا الذي تلمسه هو
هاتفك وقد ترغب في التأكد
من تنظيف أسطح
هاتفك مثل  حسنًا ، عندما تلمسه ،
غالبًا ما نقوم بذلك ولكن
هذه أشياء مهمة للتأكد من أنك
تحمي نفسك ، دعنا نلقي نظرة على
تنقلاتي اليومية فقط إذا كنت أستقل
الحافلة ، فهناك الدرابزين وزر التوقف
بالطبع طوال الوقت  أتحقق من
رسائل البريد الإلكتروني والتغريدات الخاصة بي التي
تطلب إشارة المشاة وإلى المكتب
حيث لدي مجموعتان من
الأبواب لأفتحهما بالماضي الذي أتطرق إليه عشرات
المرات في اليوم ودرجًا  طريقة للتسلق
مباشرة ، أحتاج إلى بعض الكافيين مع
اندفاعة من الحليب قبل أن يبدأ يوم عملي حتى ،
لقد لمست الأسطح العامة ما مجموعه
11 مرة وهاتفي يمكن أن يكون إجمالي
أربع مرات فقط أثناء تنقلاتي في
هواتفنا أسرّة ساخنة من البكتيريا
طبق بتري فعال في جيوبنا
، من المحتمل أن يكون هناك الكثير من
الكائنات الحية الدقيقة هناك لأنك
تمسكها بجلدك وأنت
تتعامل معها طوال الوقت ، كما
أنك تتحدث معهم
وتتحدث عن إطلاق قطرات من الماء فقط
في  الكلام العادي ، لذلك من المحتمل أن
مجموعة من الميكروبات بما في ذلك المشفرة 19 في
حالة إصابتك بهذا الفيروس
قد ينتهي بها الأمر على هاتفك ، لذا فإن إعطاء
هاتفك نظيفًا ولن يكون
فكرة سيئة على الإطلاق ، فكيف يجب علينا
تنظيف هواتفنا بدون  إلحاق الضرر
بهم ، قامت شركة Apple مؤخرًا بتحديث
إرشاداتها قائلة إنه يمكنك
مسح هاتفك إما بمناديل مطهرة أو
70٪ من كحول الأيزوبروبيل ،
يوصي مصنعو الهواتف الآخرون بمزيج من
صابون اليد والماء  وقطعة قماش ناعمة من
الألياف الدقيقة ، ما يوصون به هو
أن تأخذ أحد هذه المسحات
يمسح الأسطح الصلبة لهاتفك
أثناء محاولة تجنب أي نوع من
المنافذ المفتوحة مثل منفذ الشحن الأربعة أو
مقبس سماعة الرأس أو إذا كنت تريد أن تكون
مرتفعًا قليلاً  - يمكنك تجربة أحد
هذه المعقمات فوق البنفسجية ، ما
تفعله هو أن تدخل هاتفك لمدة 10
دقائق تقريبًا وتتركه ينطلق من الجراثيم ،
لكن ليس من الواضح بعد مدى
فعاليتها على فيروس كورونا مع الأخذ في الاعتبار أن جهاز iPhone الخاص
بي يخبرني أنني التقط هاتفي
بمعدل 205 مرة في اليوم ،
قد تكون الجبهة الأحدث في مكافحة فيروس كورونا بين
يديك الآن بالنسبة لشبكة CNN ، لقد أصبت بالبرد
في لندن
.  ما يحدث في هذا الجهاز الذي يستغرق 31 دقيقة و 55 ثانية ، لذا فإن ما يحدث هنا هو الخطوة الأخيرة في عمليتنا لاختبار الفيروسات والأطباء والباحثين في المركز الطبي بجامعة نبراسكا في أوماها في انتظار نتائج اختبار جديد هم تم تطويره من شأنه تسريع مكافحة فيروس كورونا الجديد ، وبسرعة ستعرف ما إذا كانت معلومات المرضى الواردة هنا سلبية أو إيجابية لفيروس كورونا ، سنعرف على الفور أن الاختبار الذي تم تتبعه بسرعة للحصول على موافقة إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر يأتي نظرًا لأن منظمة الصحة العالمية أعلنت أن كوفات 19 جائحة عالمي ، فقد أصبح عدم الوصول إلى الاختبار هنا في الولايات المتحدة نقطة خلاف وارتباك ، لكن بعض المستشفيات البحثية مثل المركز الطبي بجامعة نبراسكا تواصل توسيع قدرتها على القيام بذلك. -اختبار الموقع حتى يتمكن المرضى الذين يأتون من معرفة النتائج في نفس اليوم ، لذلك إذا تم اختبارك هنا من خلال البروتوكول الجديد الخاص بك
تمت الموافقة على المدة التي ستستغرقها
للحصول على النتائج حتى تكون النتائج
متاحة في غضون أربع إلى ست
ساعات وهذا يختلف بشكل ملحوظ عن
الاختبارات الأخرى التي سمعتها جيدًا والتي
تستغرق أيامًا وهذا صحيح وهذا
كل شيء يتعلق بقدرتنا على الأداء
الاختبار هنا في مختبرنا المحلي
يعتقد الطبيب أنه للحصول على
نتائج أسرع ، يجب أن تتم عملية الاختبار بأكملها
في المنشأة الطبية
حيث يتم إجراء الاختبار كما
تعلمون في جميع أنحاء البلاد ، ما زلنا
نتعامل مع التحديات التي تستغرق
أحيانًا أيام للحصول على  نتيجة الاختبار ، فإن
الكثير من ذلك يتعلق
بقرب المختبر الذي يقوم
بالاختبار في بعض الأحيان أن المختبر لا يكون
حتى في نفس الحالة ، فمن
المفيد حقًا إجراء الاختبار الذي تعرفه
في مؤسستك الخاصة مرة أخرى في المختبر.
بالنظر إلى
نتائج 20 اختبارًا أجروه قبل ساعات فقط ،
أخبرني ما كانت
نتائج الاختبار ، ويسعدني أن أبلغكم
اليوم  الدفعة الأولى من النتائج كلها
سلبية ، لذا سنكون قادرين على
نقل هذه النتائج مع الأطباء الذين
يهتمون بهؤلاء الأفراد الذين قد يكونون
جالسين في غرفة الطوارئ لدينا في الوقت الحالي في
انتظار
نتائجهم ، كم عدد الإيجابيات التي كنت
تتوقع رؤيتها كنت أتوقع ثلاثة  في هذه
الجولة اليوم ، ثلاثة من أصل عشرين ولم
يحصل على صفر ، أنتم
علماء عظماء يعتبرون هذا
السيناريو الأسوأ للبشرية مكتظًا بشدة
وتحت تهديد انتشار الوباء في
المستوطنات غير الرسمية لعشرة بيزا
الصحية ، المدافع عن الصحة تيم بالمر لرعايته ،
يقول ذلك  حتى الحماية الأساسية من
الفيروس مثل غسل يديك غير
واقعية ، لذا يتحدث الناس عن
حلول بسيطة لمنع ذلك ، لكنهم ليسوا
بهذه البساطة
، يمكن أن يكونوا بهذه البساطة ، لكنهم غير
متأكدين من أنني لا أرى ذلك ،
ويتوقع خبراء الصحة العامة العاملون أن
إفريقيا  يمكن أن تكون الأكثر تضرراً من قبل السرية 19
يقولون إن النظم الصحية لن تتأقلم ولكن
في الأشهر الأولى من تفشي المرض ،
كان هناك عدد قليل من الحالات المؤكدة التي كانت بعض
نماذج تفشي المرض قبلها.  أعلن هذا التأخر
لأن القارة لا تزال
أقل ارتباطًا نسبيًا بالمناطق الأكثر تضررًا ، حيث
ستتأثر إفريقيا بعد
أن علم بقية العالم ومسؤولو الصحة
أن الفيروس سيأتي إلى أي
جزء من العالم يمكن أن يشكل خطرًا على
أجزاء أخرى من العالم في هذا
الترابط العالمي يُمنح التأخير
العلماء الأفارقة البارزين فرصة للتحضير
في يناير / كانون الثاني ، حيث كان لدى جنوب إفريقيا
والسنغال المختبرين الوحيدان القادران على
تشخيص الفيروس الآن يمكن لأكثر من 40 دولة
اختباره ، كما أن حالات تفشي الإيبولا الأخيرة في غرب
ووسط إفريقيا قد علمت
الحياة الحيوية-  حفظ الدروس في الحجر الصحي
وتتبع الاتصال بعدة طرق ،
لا يعتبر الإيبولا مرضًا مخيفًا وقاتلًا
صعبًا على الرغم من كونه سريًا 19 ولكن إذا
كنت جميعًا في غرفة اجتماعات وكنت
قريبًا من كل هؤلاء الأشخاص ، فلن يفترض أن يتواجد كل هؤلاء الأشخاص
في برلين.  قد
يتعرضون للعدوى ، وبالتالي ترتفع الأرقام بشكل كبير
بغض النظر عما تفعله جنوب إفريقيا لاحتوائه
إذا كانت هناك حالات معدية في أي مكان آخر في العالم
د وليس هناك طريقة
يمكننا حقًا من إيقاف
حركة مرض تنفسي مثل هذا ،
قوة العدوى هذه قوية
وربما كل ما يمكنهم فعله هو إبطاء
الانتشار ، لذلك نحن جاهلون جميعًا
لا نعرف ما
الذي نسمعه للتو  من الراديو: أعتقد أن
كوهانا وصلت هل تعلم هل أنت
قلق أنا مواطن صادق أنا في
تامبا وما زال الناس في جميع أنحاء القارة
يتوقعون أسوأ
ديفيد ماكنزي سي إن إن جوهانسبرج جنوب
أفريقيا